all right I have more to add for you on
the Quest for 1.5 million YouTube
subscribers we are dangerously close we
are now only looks like
3156 subscribers away
from 1.5 million and we have a bunch of
stuff on the calendar people have been
writing in saying David if you can get
to the 1.5 million sooner here's what
I'm willing to do and this is just for
fun okay everybody relax it's not like a
big deal people are just having a good
time all right if we get to the 1.5
million by October 4th at sundown I will
do the Yom Kippur fast I never do the
Yom Kippur fast I will do it and I will
live blog how bad it is to do the sunset
to Sunset fast for Yom Kippur okay if we
get to the 1.5 million by October 5th
I will obtain a unicycle and post a
video of me trying to ride a unicycle
down the street I've never done it this
was suggested by Anne from Utah and now
I have other things to add if we can get
to the 1.5 million by October 10th Bo
will get a bag of mangoes tattooed with
some kind of tagline from the show Bo
says his wife is a tattoo artist in New
York City and he already has a bunch of
tattoos and he's willing to get a mango
David Pacman show related tattoo if we
make it to 1.5 million subscribers by
October 10th October 12th Chris is a
muralist in Atlanta meaning that he
paints murals and he says if we get to
1.5 million by October 12th which is his
birthday he will paint a David pakman
show mural in Atlanta photograph it and
send it to us I think that that would be
absolutely awesome Kurt says that if we
get to the 1.5 million by October 21 he
will get a Mount Rushmore tattoo on his
back except it'll be Biden Obama Clinton
FDR and me which kind of scares me but
it sounds interesting and then Kelsey
says that if we make it by November 4th
which we really should
she will bake and decorate a custom uh
vegan David Pacman show cupcake and send
pictures and one will say Obama and
another will be Alex Jones or whatever
okay so she's going to do custom show
related cupcakes if we make it by
November 4th so two things one if you're
not subscribed Please Subscribe
youtube.com the davidpackman show the
earlier we get to the 1.5
the more of these hijinks that we will
be able to uh engage in and then
secondly if you have something to add to
the calendar like if you want to say you
know David if you make it by October 6th
I will I
something you can email info
davidpackman.com
one of our long time sponsors is monk
pack offering low sugar plant-based keto
friendly bars I love these they are the
perfect snack for anyone trying to eat
better or cutting back on sugar and
carbs without sacrificing taste monk
pack offers granola bars and nut and
Seed bars each with only one gram of
sugar or less two to three net carbs and
150 calories or less I'm a big fan of
the macadamia white chocolate nut and
Seed bar great combination of sweet
salty chewy and crunchy and there's
under one gram of sugar they come in
other awesome flavors like sea salt dark
chocolate coconut cocoa chip and caramel
sea salt monk pack is great if you're
doing keto I don't do keto but monk pack
is just great for anyone who wants
something delicious On The Go without
the sugar and my audience gets 20 off
your first order at monk pack Com when
you use the coupon code Pacman at
checkout the link is down below